on doit terminer les abdiqué minutes
comme source du nrj facile par 2030
[Musique]
elizabeth may catégorique le canada doit
se débarrasser du pétrole d'ici 2030 et
durant la transition
les verts proposent d'interdire toute
importation de pétrole étranger incluant
le pétrole américaines le canada produit
assez de pétrole pour être autosuffisant
mais se fie uniquement au pétrole
canadien le temps de compléter la
transition n'est pas l'option la plus
écologique
disons que le canada fait du jour au
lendemain une croix sur le pétrole
américains pour répondre à la demande il
faudra se rabattre sur le pétrole de
l'alberta les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre liées au pétrole des sables
bitumineux sont en moyenne 10 7% plus
élevé que le pétrole des états unis
pour mettre fin complètement aux
importations de pétrole il faudrait
aussi forcé la raffinerie un vignes de
saint jean au nouveau brunswick
achetez uniquement le pétrole brut
produit au large de terre-neuve comme la
plateforme hibernia ne produit pas
suffisamment de bari faudrait aussi que
hurling acceptent de réduire d'au moins
de moitié sa capacité de raffinage
selon certains experts la seule façon
d'y arriver serait de nationaliser
revint en fermant d'un seul coup la
porte aux produits pétroliers américains
que le canada pourrait faire face à des
pénuries et à une grande volatilité des
prix bref si durant la transition on
n'utilise que du pétrole canadien est
bien le chemin vers la fin du pétrole
risque d'être beaucoup plus chaotique